[музика]
вітаємо Ласкаво просимо на програму
фокусі Європа раді бачити вас сьогодні
щороку швейно промисловість усьому світі
викидає більше СО2 ніж сукупні викиди
вантажок кораблі літаків згідно з
оцінкою програми ООН з навколишнього
середовища
А за останні два десятиліття кількість
вживаного одягу що експортується
європейськими країнами потроїлася
майже половина цього експорту надходить
сюди в Африку де його здебільшого
повторно використовують місцеві жителі
попит високий але екологи попереджають
що ці купи старого одягу не приносять
користі то на його опиняється на
величезних відкритих звалищах
забруднюючи навколишнє середовище і
роблячи непридатними ресурси які можна
було використовувати повторно і
переробляти
Європа потребує переосмислення каже
Аліса тессі і вона може підкріпити свої
слова діями
її Сімейний бізнес у центрі моди в
Італії займається переробкою відходів і
вона не єдина витискання навколо міста
Прато виробляється майже 15% усього
переробленого одягу у світі тисячі
текстильних компаній створюють нове зі
старого завдяки чому брату швидко стало
Парижем екомоди
такий контейнер для вживаного одягу може
стояти майже у будь-якому Європейському
місці Але де б він не знаходився швидше
за все одяг потрапить до Прато Італія
світовою столиці переробки текстилю
близько 150 і 700 текстильних компаній
тут займаються переробкою
вживаний одяг з Німеччини Австрії та
Швейцарії потрапляє на склад Сальваторе
ранчіно
[музика]
тут ми сортуємо все що надходить
футболки штани дитячий одяг светри і
куртки все це ми сортуємо відповідно до
сезону зима чи літо
дві третини одягу він перепродає
переважно в Африку
Аліса тессі яка працює по сусідству
забирає останню третину її Сімейний
бізнес вже 4 покоління переробляє
вживаний одяг на пряжу і тканину
[музика]
тут починається магія зрештою викинуті
речі стануть новою пряжею Та вовною це
складний процес який починається тут
наша мета повернути пряжі й первісний
колір ми розділяємо кольори а потім наша
машина перетворює ганчірки на своєрідну
волокнисту масу Таким чином ми
відновлюємо первісний колір без хімічних
барвників
хімічні барвники лише одна з проблем
сучасної текстильної промисловості
у всьому світі 20% забруднення води
походить від фарбування та оздоблення
тканин це ще одна причина чому переробка
вживаного одягу така важлива
[музика]
потім матеріал потрапляє на нашу
промивну станцію де його подрібнюють і
перетворюють назад на сировину воду яку
ми використовуємо Ми беремо з глибини
150 метрів ми фільтруємо її а потім
відправляємо безпосередньо на очисну
станцію тож ми переробляємо і воду
її компанія переробляє до 25 тонн
тканини на день кінцевий продукт Ось
такі пухнасті волокна
матеріал висухи тепер має таку ж
вологість як і початкове волокно
тепер його можна пакувати і продавати
або прясти з нього пряжу
процес переробки продовжується на
сусідній фабриці
волокна перетворюються на пряжу а потім
на тканину кожен європеєць купує в
середньому 26 кілограмів текстилю на рік
[музика]
більшість його зрештою опиняється на
звалищі для Аліси це жахливе
марнотратство
ми намагаємось внести свою маленьку
лепту звісно якби індустрія моди
наслідувала наш приклад ми могли б
досягти набагато більшого важко повірити
що лише 1% усього використаного одягу у
світі переробляється і 15% із цього
одного відсотка переробляється тут у
брато тож так наш внесок тут у
текстильному районі Прато важливий
батько Аліси президент італійської
асоціації з переробки текстилю але він
каже що перероблені тканини не можуть
бути єдиним рішенням
продури На даний момент ми не можемо
задовольнити світовий промисловий і
споживчий попит на 100% переробленої
матеріалами
що ми маємо зробити зараз так це дати
зрозуміти наскільки важливо все більше і
більше рухатися в напрямку переробки
це також означає заохочення молодих
дизайнерів наприклад студентів академії
моди які використовують перероблений
текстиль з правду для своїх творіння
у центрі prato стартап ріфо уже продає
дизайнерський одяг з переробленого
текстилю по всьому світу мета Ніколо
чіпріані об’єднати ремісничу методи
екологічну меду та принципи циркулярної
економіки
він переконаний що якісний одяг може
бути етичним та екологічним
ми бачимо що все більше людей
цікавляться цими питаннями і готові
купувати менше одягу але платити більше
за якість
[музика]
це протилежність швидкій моді яку ми
бачили ще кілька років тому тоді все
було про низькі ціни і частіше купівлю
нового одягу
Такі люди як Ніколо та Аліса показують
що екологічна мода - Це більше ніж
просто мрія Більше таких місць Як Прато
по всьому світу можуть допомогти зробити
її реальністю
якщо щось має змінитися в кліматичному
плані то на думку денна Едельштейна та
хілларі пауелл Хтось має це почати
сьогодні вони піонери Сонячної
енергетики але лондонці хочуть
використовувати енергію сонця не лише
для того щоб виробляти електроенергію
для себе вони хочуть щоб якомога більше
сусідів також переобладнували свої
будинки ідея в тому що взяти одну вулицю
або навіть цілий район і створити
об'єднану сонячну електростанцію і вони
вже почали це робити
нові сонячні панелі нарешті тут і
незабаром Ця вулиця вироблятиме власну
електроенергію мешканці вулиці
східному Лондоні більше двох років
працювали над цим і переконували своїх
сусідів приєднатися до проекту сьогодні
їхня мрія стає реальністю
тиск від слів про те що щось має статися
і плакати електростанцій на вікнах Це
перша мить коли ми бачимо що це стає
реальністю і так це певне полегшення це
радість ми хотіли щоб уся вулиця
отримала сонячні панелі що було нашою
метою але незабаром зрозуміли що цього
не станеться оскільки спочатку буде дуже
важко переконати хоч когось ми ці діла
ріпаул та Ден едельстин придумали цю
ідею Спочатку вони сподівалися об'єднати
всю вулицю в одну мережу але деякі дахи
не пристосовані для сонячних панелей а
деякі сусіди ще не підтримали цю ідею
але 25 домогосподарства натролу дуже при
єдналися до проекту Я думаю що по всій
Британії є мільйони людей які хочуть
подолати кліматичну кризу і вкласти
гроші у це якщо ви можете запропонувати
пряме рішення яке ми тут і створили то
воно буде досить добре сприйняти широкою
громадськістю
враховуючи економічну кризу в країні не
всі могли дозволити собі приєднатися до
проекту
тому двоє митців розпочали кампанію зі
збору коштів яка зібрала понад 100 тисяч
фунтів стерлінгів
вони навіть провели кілька тижнів зими
на даху свого будинку і зняли це на
відео у якості краудфандингу
ми хотіли зробити цю вулицю не лише
місцем де розгортається історія але і
експериментальним прототипом пілотним
зразком який Міг би допомогти іншим
швидко почати діяти знадобилося багато
ідей невдалих спроб щоб знайти модель
яка б працювала
активісти кажуть що уряд має
підтримувати такі інноваційні екологічні
проекти щоб допомогти подолати
кліматичну кризу
Нам потрібні значні кошти щоб людям було
максимально легко отримати дотацію або
субсидію для того щоб перетворити свої
будівлі будинки чи підприємства на
електростанції
гілларі паул і Ден едельстин знімають
встановлення сонячних панелей перший
крок на шляху до Сонячної вулиці
їхня сусідка Анжела сподівається що
сонячні панелі допоможуть їй скоротити
рахунки за електроенергію
цей проект буде дуже корисним для
планети якщо він не зупиниться і
продовжить розвиватися Колись люди
побачать як це відбувається Ви знаєте це
тільки початок І звісно рахунки будуть
дешевшими
поки що такі будинки на сонячній енергії
тут усе ще рідкість їхній партнер велика
британська енергетична компанія каже що
вони перші у цій галузі
тут у Великій Британії у нас одна з
найстаріших енергосистем вона дуже
залежить від викупного палива і в пікові
години скажімо о 6 годині вечора коли
Люди приходять додому і хочуть
приготувати вечерю мережа задію кілька
сотень різних генераторів щоб
задовольнити цей попит це призводить до
Жахливого забруднення довкілля і звісно
коштує дуже дорого у сонячні дні
Лондонський піонери Сонячної енергетики
можуть навіть виробляти надлишкову
енергію яку можна подавати у загальну
мережу істерика
замість мережі на викупному паливі ми
виступаємо за децентралізацію цієї
мережі і натомість можемо мати тисячі
різних об'єктів відновлювальної
енергетики які самі контролюють мережу і
створюють цю гнучкість
відтепер такі страви будуть готуватися
за допомогою енергії яка надходить прямо
із їх власного даху
коли решта вулиці побачуть перші 10-20
будинків із сонячними панелями і вони
побачать що це життєздатна ідея а не
вигадка кількох митців які просто мають
якусь чудернацьку ідею Сподіваємось що
більше людей захочуть долучитися до
проекту
І ми також сподіваємося що зможемо
заощадити гроші за рахунок оптових
закупівель і подібних речей щоб залучати
і інші вулиці
що це лише початок їхня мрія енергія для
людей у кожному куточку міста
президент Росії Володимир Путін опинився
під тиском
короткочасне повстання групи найманців
Вагнера поставили під сумнів
стабільність його владного апарату
а тут ще й ордер на арешт виданий проти
нього міжнародним кримінальним судом в
газі за депортацію тисячі українських
дітей до Росії
наприклад Ігоря він один з майже 20
тисяч дітей які за даними України були
викрадені в рамках військових операцій і
військових злочинів Росії лише деякі цих
дітей змогли повернутися додому до своїх
батьків Ігор один з тих небагатьох кому
пощастило
узбережжі Чорногорії одне з
найкрасивіших на адріатичному морі і
воно дуже популярне серед багатих росіян
які полюбляють нам відпочивати Міко
вуксанович живе за рахунок цього туризму
коли він виходить у море на своєму
катері як зараз він пропливає величезні
розкішні яхти які за чутками належить
олігархам але він зустрічає багато
звичайних росіян які втекли до
середземноморської республіки рятуючись
від путінської війни
Ніко в оксановіч катає туристів на
своєму катері щоб вони могли
насолодитися красою будви Чорногорія
популярне місце відпочинку
спочатку війни в Україні вона стала
прихистком для багатьох росіян
яхту у порту належать їм
це лише припущення ми не знаємо чиї вони
але багато з них належать чорногорцям
ходять чутки що багато і російських яхт
Можливо але не тут
в оксановіч каже що яхта які належать
супербагатіям швидше за все швартуються
за кілька кілометрів на північ у тіваті
влучне припущення у розкішні Гавані
Порту Монтенегро стоять кілька супер яхт
яхта trident що пришвартована тут
завдовжки цілих 65 метрів її власник не
російський а український Олігарх проти
якого США запровадили санкції але
офіційний яхтовий реєстр показує що
кожна третя яхта у Чорногорії належить
росіянину більшість із них не підпадають
під дію ембарго узбережжі Чорногорії
особливо місто Будва було улюбленим
місцем відпочинку росіян протягом
десятиліть Вони мають тісні зв'язки
історичні та мовні
в оксановіч показує нам духлю яку
росіяни побудували За два кроки від
будови
це дуже привабливе місце і доволі дороге
Кажуть що всі не та від 8 до 9 тисяч
євро за квадратний метр квартира може
запросто коштувати мільйон
Хоча багато хто тут заробляє на життя
туризмом Навряд чи хтось із місцевих
жителів отримує вигоду від цього
туристичного Бубу І багато хто не
задоволений тим як все змінилося
хотілося б що було частіше вони будуть
скрізь але не саджають ніяких рослин усі
зелені зони зникли
орендна плата це погано для орендарів Ми
не можемо дозволити собі таку орендну
плату зі звичайним доходом до Чорногорії
З'їжджаються не лише супер багаті
росіяни інші приїхали сюди щоб
врятуватися від путінської війни
наприклад Артем він відпочивав у
Таїланді з другом коли Путін мобілізував
свої війська
у Росії я не можу вільно говорити і
висловлювати свої думки через певні
закони і через мільйони інших причин
Росія це небезпечне місце і Це очевидно
а тут я відчуваю Ну просто вау наче
ковток свіжого повітря я можу дихати тут
на повну
коли я був дитиною я казав що хочу жити
у цікаві часи
це зовсім не те що я собі уявляв це
гірко гірко так
тому що я відчуваю що у нас вкрали
країну з майбутнім і я не впевнений що є
спосіб швидко це виправити це нереально
Артем працює у барбершопі він не
переймається щодо свого майбутнього але
іноді буває важко каже він наприклад
коли його власне мати вірить путінський
пропаганді
stoneer
і в мене з'явилися багато витримки щоб
змінити своє життя Ну і таке інше
Я розумію що я можу все насправді
і мені дуже потрібна підтримка і такі
люди як я теж потребують підтримки
ми всі в одному човні в цьому океані
насильства
[музика]
на узбережжі Адріатики це насильство
практично непомітне які більшість
чорногорців і Міку в оксановичу не дуже
скаржиться на нову прибулих але одна річ
його турбує
вони не мають жодного уявлення про море
це не частина їхньої культури вода риба
усе що робить море море
Його улюблена Будва змінюється але він
сподівається що місто все одно збереже
свій Шарм і красу
футбол це зазвичай про те щоб
спостерігати за гравцями світового класу
котрі роблять речі про які ми можемо
тільки мріяти вони ще лігах все інакше
там тактика може ламатися темперамент
розгорятися А на полі іноді буває більше
ніж 11 гравців і в Словаччині це
ідеальний рецепт для некласичного виду
розваг
запал радість невдачі
[музика]
справжня футбольна історія пишеться з
нуля
і чим більше приземлене поле Тим більш
чесне змагання
І все Це секрет найпопулярнішого
футбольного каналу Словаччини інша ліга
їхні камери працюють лише на матчах 7
Ліги і нижче
щотижня випускається репортаж про три
матчі і такі сюжети збирають сотні тисяч
переглядів
[музика]
у Чорному балузі біля підніжжя нижніх
татр досі тихо
сюди ще не дійшли чутки про те що
сьогоднішній матч буде увічнений в
аналах Словацького футболу але звісно
вболівальники тут знають що таке інша
ліга
сільський футбол - це дещо дуже
особливим Ви відчуваєте те чого вже
немає вищих лігах ці справжні емоції і
вони розпалюються ще сильніше в цьому
дереві
легендарний словацький голкіпер ледіслав
мальнар бере інтерв'ю у гравців до і
після гри аналізує склад команд та
документує казуси за межами поля
інша ліга була ідеєю якоба бубеніка
Понад мільйон переглядів при тому що
населення Словаччини становить 5,5
доводять що задум вдався
рівень гри часто не найкращий
але я так багато особливих моментів які
варті того щоб про них розповісти ви
побачите що це футбол у його
найпростішому розумінні неелітний футбол
людям цікаво лише найкраще або лише
найгірше а тут все так природно від
щирого серця
місцевій команді татранський чорний
балог сьогодні потрібна перемога щоб
перейти у вищу лігу але перший тайм вони
програють і з рахунком 1:0
жорстка настанова від тренера в
роздягальні випити можна буде тільки за
перемогу
аж раптом несподіванка для команди
гостей прямо на матч приїжджає потяг
гравці чорного балугу ставляться до
цього спокійно стадіон був побудований
уздовж залізничних колій
гра закінчується з рахунком 1:1 але інша
ліга - це насправді про історії а не про
кінцевий результат і ще 10 тисяч
переглядів зібрало незвичайне
протистояння німецький Репортер проти
Словацького воротаря легенди
незалежно від результату головне
отримати задоволення у цьому уся суть
ліги
як на мене найголовніше тут третій Тайм
Коли ви йдете пити пиво з іншої командою
А на сьогодні це все дякуємо за перегляд
Бережіть себе і до зустрічі наступного
випуску У фокусі Європи телекомпанії
Deutsche Welle
українською мовою звучало центром Меді
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]